um yeah happy to be here and um yeah
let's just dive into it you already
mentioned my title and I hope you're all
in the right session
and yeah just a quick intro to myself
I'm Leah I'm a data scientist and data
product manager at innovex and we also
have a booth here so if you want to talk
to me or other my colleagues um just
come around I as Max already mentioned I
have a PhD in Behavior economics back
then I was really interested in biases
and
human decisions in economic context but
now I'm more interested in how these
human biases actually crawl into our
models and data products and there are
also some other topics I'm really
interested in in my free time I enjoy
doing all sorts of sports
um yeah so um
I guess you have seen these kind of
things before AI gone bad it's how I
called it and there are a lot of yeah
headlines you've seen
um where algorithmic decisions are taken
under this kind of veil of fairness so
they because they're done by a machine
there they have to be objective they
have to be fair but actually we saw that
there are some some things which went
wrong and they'll yeah there's actually
there's a whole database for all these
kind of incidents and other situations
where you actually maybe you shouldn't
have built a thing in the first place
and maybe shouldn't use an algorithm for
it maybe also in a context where this is
not really
um going right there was this outcry in
the UK when they used an algorithm to
kind of predict the grades for the A
Levels um and well
the algorithm in itself wasn't really
wrong or the model wasn't wrong but
um the objective was maybe wrong there
were some biases baked into the
algorithm so
um it yeah it didn't go out
um well so uh yeah there's also
yeah lots of examples I guess you've
seen some of them and if you're
interested yeah just check them out so I
hope this is motivation enough why we
should care about this
um and
what do you care just like for a big
wrap up for what kind of Dimensions we
have and um what facets of data and our
eye ethics or responsible trustworthy AI
they're all terms that are kind of used
interchangeably
um I took kind of four things uh from
the Turing Institute just to wrap your
head around it so fairness first of all
is a really important notion
um so non-discrimination
um Equitable in the input and outputs
and which then leads to unbiased
implementation
um I know it's kind of a vague concept
and
um yeah oftentimes it just depends so
it's kind of context specific how
fairness will really look like but it's
still something you should
um wrap your head around in the very
first place then accountability of
course is is quite important and I would
guess it will become more important with
the uai Act and where auditing is
necessary and you really need to answer
questions about how your model is taking
decisions that factors are counted in
and
um yeah that we have humans in the loop
across the whole process
um from inputs to outputs and there's
even though automation is cool
um sometimes there should be human
having some oversight and review of the
things there
um sustainability
um yeah of course there are like
I really like this term of that data
products are social technical so they
really don't
um exist on their own but they we we as
people we interact and they have real
life impacts on us and so they have
transformative effects and um their
decisions which are taken with
algorithms so people get alone get a job
get it missed the admission to a
university so they really have impact on
on society and how we proceed in life
and yeah safety is the last Point here
which obviously is also really important
um
yeah and then last but not least
transparency
um so really need to be able to explain
there's lots of efforts also to document
um what you have how you how your
algorithm Works in a way that also the
kind of general public understands it
and you really need to be able to prove
that what you are doing is is ethical
and as I said already it's it's also
something which will become more
important there I took this from a
touring Institute I Like This Acronym
fast or something you can remember but
of course there are also different
dimensions from different
um yeah sites but I think it captures
quite quite well what we should care
about and so now uh now since we settled
the grounds I want to dive into my
actual
um content so I want to look into the
life cycle of a data product so I guess
many of you have seen this before and I
want to go through each step and look
where I buy we could biases and crawl
into here and what could go wrong at
each stage so since time is short I will
really dive into the business
understanding that's the first part and
this is actually before we have written
any the first line of code so it really
this is the question of whether the
product should be built in the first
place so really think about what's the
purpose and the need behind the product
that you want to build and whether the
outcomes could have negative effects on
society or particular groups so this is
really important that even if on by by
by large it might have positive impact
there might be groups which are
suffering because of what the product is
doing and so it it could be a way to
reinforce or reiterate um discrimination
past discrimination which comes from the
data that is already biased
um also thinking about the stakeholders
do they have implicit assumptions are
they actually valid do they have biases
or blind spots and then looking into the
kind of kpis for a product how will the
performance be evaluated how will be
defined that the product is successful
in the end and so these are the things
that you should really think about and
there are ways to kind of structure your
thinking about it so in general I think
it's it's really important to always
look at the big picture to understand
the main goal
um by this you can do like yeah gather
background information talk to the main
experts really try to collect diverse
views and expertise Microsoft has this
responsible Innovation toolkit which I
quite like they have certain
Frameworks and activities which can put
you in a place to really look into these
um uh yeah into product from different
sites and kind of really write down what
kind of potential risk there are also do
maybe interviews with different
stakeholders you haven't done before
this is also it's not only to be ethical
but actually also I think to build
better products in general they're also
self-assessment tools and yeah as always
it's really important to really speak
out and communicate concerns and risk
and discuss about it so this would be
the first stage um after product life
cycle and if this is this is already
said we would um dive into the data look
at the data um and here of course
informed content is a is a very
important factor so are you actually
allowed to use the data for what you you
you want to use it for so
um nowadays there was quite some
discussion about it we know that chat
GPT was banned in Italy because of that
because
um
they use oftentimes data which is
available on the internet but is this
really informed concept of the people
that are providing this data then what
is really important
um to understand how the data is
generated what is the process
um is there already maybe some kind of
biases
um within the data generation process so
where where do they come from how are
they generated really makes sense to
really look also on the other side so
for example if it's human generated data
um how does the process behind look like
are they missing things
um which affect the data quality or how
data is structured and of course if also
for labels if you use labels for your
data for supervised learning and really
look into how are they generated if
they're human labeled there's quite a
high risk that there are also some kind
of biases involved here so really ask
yourself who did it where was it done
when and what for
um training data of course should be
representative of the target population
sometimes it's really hard to find out
how your target population looks like
but really check for for distributions
and and look
um whether it's representative data
quality I already mentioned it's either
systematic deviations
um in the in the quality so either
systematically missing values
um wrong values these kind of things and
also one important thing do we actually
induce bias within our data preparation
process so
um I will also discuss it in the next
slide a little bit more so
um yeah how do we actually process the
data do we discretize certain values
this might affect
um also the distribution of the data so
um a good start is to start documenting
your data sets um even though it's just
a documentation kind of thing but it
really helps you to extract get a
structure and ask yourself a lot of
questions you might not ask yourself
um beforehand check for the privacy of
protected attributes there are different
methods to do that I don't want to go
into detail here and of course I yeah I
guess we all know that Eda is important
but really do it thoroughly so really
check the distribution and quality of
your input data as I said the
representation of different groups
events and so on what is the data
Quality Distribution across the whole
data set but also for different
subgroups
other systematically missing values and
there are lots of tools out there I just
put this one here where you can really
easily
um visually inspect your data and and
check for for deviations outliers and
these kind of things
um then check for the impact that your
pre-processing efforts actually have so
maybe you remove uh observations with
missing values this can have a strong
impact if there's some system behind
that
um also when you impute values this can
really affect these kind of things and
once you realize there is a problem with
the data it's maybe imbalanced there are
also some methods to actually correct
for this with re-weighting over
unassembling and so on
okay now we have our data set
um we can actually go to the data
modeling part so
um
here really think about what are the
underlying mechanics and assumptions of
the algorithm which are the metrics
you're optimizing for are they really
um is it feeding into your final goal um
or are we maybe also trading accuracy
for explainability when you use
pre-trained models um which is quite
popular right now really think about the
initial context and the intended use
this always comes from the data so what
kind of data is used to train those
models does it actually reflect
um your current use case as well and um
in within your model are you using
sensitive attributes or actually it's
quite important I should have put this
in board actually or any of their
proxies because some of the features are
quite straightforward that they can be
discriminatory but
um it's even more risky if you use any
proxy so maybe a postal code could be a
proxy for a certain ethnicity and if you
use this in the first place it might not
look like it's anything really sensitive
but this can really uh bias your model
and it's in this way it's way harder to
detect so oftentimes it makes sense to
actually have those attributes in place
and then be able to detect and and
correct for it and then
um yeah are the outcomes of your model
fair and unbiased are specific groups
discriminated against
um yeah so how do we approach this so in
a sense I guess it's nothing new but
it's always good to start with simpler
and explainable more glass ball glass
box models approach
um where you can really understand what
what other mechanics how does the data
look like how what different features
what kind of effects do they have also I
really
um yeah like this kind of more
mathematical modeling approach where you
start with the domain knowledge you
check what is actually at hand what is
taking place in the real world and try
to put this into mathematical language
and into a model and then go ahead from
there and yeah of course there are also
lots of interpretability and
explainability methods out there feature
important and Analysis where you can
find spurious correlations which can
point you towards these kind of proxies
I was talking about
integration of fairness constraints as
something you can
um you can yeah also make sure that
maybe you already Within your training
you already optimized also for fairness
or put constraints in there and once
you've done that you also should check
for these kind of heterogeneous effects
and disparate impacts so as I yeah it's
kind of yeah again about those subgroups
also check for interactions you might be
seeing that there is no effect on on
race or gender but maybe if you if you
interacted that maybe black women are
actually
uh discriminated against or something
like that so this is also important to
be aware that
um different combinations might be
affected and this is especially when
there are small like they reflect only a
small part of the data and then there's
essentially a high risk that there is um
that there's something wrong here and
once you find that there's a bias there
are also some bias removal strategies
you can put here it's hard to really
generalize but you can check it and you
need to find the right tool for your for
your use case and for your model and
there's some um yeah I just put the IBM
fairness toolkit here they have lots of
these um strategies implemented some
metrics as well so it's uh it's a good
way to to start
um using this kind of metrics as well
okay going to the evaluation so it's
somehow related But first you have your
model you try out different things you
already evaluate about it but then once
you kind of are you have chosen your
model you also want to evaluate it um
with respect to not only the machine
learning metrics but also more like the
business side kpis and um this is where
um yeah we should ask ourselves whether
we are using appropriate and fair
performance metrics
um are there any trade-offs that we can
see that we are
um yeah we are seeing in our models and
yeah I can't repeat it enough but really
does the model performance vary across
subgroups we have seen some examples
where
um I think it was yeah in Facebook they
saw that their the facial recognition
um algorithm really performed really
badly on on black people but now they
actually reported on their site they put
some model cards out there and really
report
um how they perform and I think they
they managed to get it across uh equal
performance around then not only
what does your model say and how it's
performed on your model but how does are
these results interpreted and
communicated so I guess many of you have
heard about confirmation bias oftentimes
we just want to confirm our previous
assumptions and um we really need to
challenge ourselves for that as well and
um when there are problematic factors
um yeah they should be really either
really transparent and are they pointed
out maybe in the documentation but also
when you present results of course to um
to uh business to the business
and yeah what are the tools or
approaches we should take so of course
make sure that also the test set is
balanced and representative
um that the model performance reporting
is really differentiated so really
rather use an assemble of performance
metrics which makes sure that you also
see these kind of trade-offs that I was
talking about this Aggregate and slice
based evaluation
um there's also yeah tools for that and
yeah I really also make sure that you
use a combination of quantitative and
qualitative measures
um because like looking into the data
checking for certain use cases certain
personas and how the model behaves is
quite important and yeah and certainly
quantification especially when it comes
to subgroups which have really small
representation there's a high risk that
the results are somehow
really yeah overfitted and somehow
uncertain and then you should actually
try to also um make this transparent
um you can integrate fairness measures
and in general just really stress test
your model
um check for different situations
um
to really know how your model behaves
and communicate those kind of
uncertainties risks and trade-offs
um yeah so then we come to the last part
for the deployment monitoring so once
your yeah your model is is ready and
evaluated and we want to put it into
production and yeah this is actually the
last step where you can check whether
ethical requirements are fulfilled you
obviously you should really care about
this already beforehand but this is the
last chance you you have for that and
um you need to check whether your data
is starting protected in secured place
and once it is in place it's actually
quite important that we also monitor
future performance so we're not done
here
um
the model lives then and
um you know data change and so there
might be biases get introduced into
um into the model
and whether they will be detected and uh
yeah we'll be able to correct it again
and where we would whether we would be
able to track back the source of the
buyers
and
yeah there's some tools so again um
there's this it's a checklist of course
it's always only as good as the use the
usage of it but um there are some ethics
checklists from Dion which you can
actually directly Implement into your
repo you can make it really easy to make
these
um these requests and requirements
transparent
um model cards is also something yeah I
I would believe that it would become a
standard in the future and to really
report what the model is doing what data
you're using what are you available
evaluating on so really make it
transparent
um and then yeah the last part is mostly
General ml Ops best practices so
performance monitoring really check the
Quality Distribution of input and output
data and track performance and you can
just use these models and these these
tools also
um for for fairness metrics and
monitoring how you perform on different
subgroups and so on and of course yeah
Ensure reproducibility but this yeah
this is something which I guess is best
practice but also important when you
think about
um
fairness and biases and yeah human in
the loop I already mentioned is
something also quite helpful so not
automate everything so really check
um on a regular basis how you're
performing
okay so um yeah I'm at the end of my
talk so some takeaways
um
first it's it's a really broad topic
um the the resources can be quite
overwhelming I can tell from experience
but um just start uh also bringing the
topic into the table um because we need
this awareness and it's it's a
prerequisite and because if you don't
see it we can't fix it
um as you've seen it this at every stage
of the the life cycle there can be
biases introduced so
um make sure that you're aware of that
there are lots of tools that you can use
for that
um you need to find the right tools for
your use case but there's a lot of out
there
um so make use of it and of course start
the communication
um bring this ethical concerns to the
table really discuss with stakeholders
about this and um speak up and because
yeah it's my profession my personal
opinion but I think we as data
professionals have a responsibility here
and we should we should comply to it
yes so um thank you very much uh if you
have any questions I'm happy to answer
them
right on time actually
[Applause]
so yeah I'm happy I stick to the time
um I could actually talk for hours about
this topic but
um yeah I only signed up for a 30 minute
slot so thank you Lou that was a really
interesting and informative talk and I
think especially nowadays this is a
really big question and I'm glad that
you're out there trying to help people
answer that question so thank you
um I do have just a few questions for
you
um so the first one I've got here comes
from IFA
um who asks and how do I know the
intended use for data collected in llms
how do I know what the intended uses
should be actually documenting these
kind of model cards um so especially for
release models I think it's something
very important
um if not I guess it's something where
we should also get into contact and
maybe actually ask for this because
um just because everyone using it uses
it it's not something you should just
use straight away so
um yeah we should read the manual read
the manual yeah awesome okay I've got
just a few more uh and a few coming in
as well
um let's see so I'll just ask you this
one
um so just a quick question here
um is there such a thing as good
unbiased data
yeah that's a difficult question and I
also already pointed towards it because
fairness and representativeness is
really hard to Define and maybe
representativeness more
um
I guess just not really unbiased data
but you should be aware and you should
see
um and yeah
and try to take measures to make it more
suiting to your kind of fairness Notions
and yeah
maybe sensor data I don't know
sure
um thank you um there's there's a few
more coming in now actually so we've got
a few to ask you if you're okay I'm fine
if we don't get to your question by the
way Leia will be around for the rest of
the conference and at the end of X Booth
as well so you'll be able to find her
but for now I'll just ask you is there a
list of minorities that uh maybe or
other some minorities maybe that are you
know discriminated against more commonly
that maybe we need to be aware of that
like maybe you aren't as known like
maybe there's a group that maybe you're
not aware of
I I have never seen like a general list
for it but I guess it's um things that
that we
um see a lot is is gender age
um uh social background
um
uh ethnicity obviously a religion these
kind of things so
um these are the more straightforward
but there might be other groups and
there might be also particular for your
use case and um
yeah I would say the more you you have a
broader picture the better
awesome okay
um so keeping going we've got a few more
um this is popular popular lots of
questions so the next question is um
have you got an example that you can
share for a fairness constraint and how
do you make sure that a fairness
constraints does not include any bias
yeah so I guess
I guess quite straightforward example
would be that when you have I guess uh
yeah
um facial recognition software or
something where you see that
um it should be like the constraint
could be that you should it should be
equally
um or like the deviation between
performances across different groups
shouldn't be too large so we should be
make sure that even if there are smaller
groups um we also perform
um similarly well because if you know if
there's actually a minority it might get
fed into if you just look at the average
um you might not even see that
performance is quite bad for for this
particular group
awesome okay
um and a question here from Christian
who asks uh re-waiting data re-waiting
data sounds nice
um but that's only possible once you
already know the bias and is there a
general data sanitation approach that
you might take to avoid biases
um well as I said there's not really a
general one to avoid biases I think it's
something as I said also it's you need
to consider in every step and
um yeah re-rating is something I think
for example in survey data that I did
quite do quite a lot to get a
representative sample so oftentimes if
they do service there is some kind of
um yeah some kind of imbalance towards
certain groups and then they kind of
just re-weight certain observations
um but of course it's also tricky if you
if you don't have this knowledge about
what is actually the the target
distribution whether you have those
features actually which allow to to
track back these kind of features as
well so like attributes of
um yeah of certain subgroups so
yeah it's hard to say there's a general
approach
um
but
yeah just be aware in every step and and
think whether there is something some
buyers get introduced there yeah I think
that's why what I took from your talk
too and it's it's important at every
stage just to be really pragmatic and
really work out what you can get from
yeah from this kind of following this
process and we've got a few more just
coming in last minute so there's one
here
um do you think some organizations can
have incentives to exploit and
exacerbate biases and if so how might we
deal with that as a community
um I definitely think so I think we
currently seeing it a little bit so
um being the first one being the fastest
one might actually want you to skip
these kind of considerations and we have
seen yeah some examples where people get
fired because of that and um and
economic incentives are more in the
Forefront but
um yeah in the long run maybe just
regulation can solve this issue because
um and I think there are yeah there are
some initiatives about it I'm not sure
um are still uh yeah looking forward to
see how this really affects
um these kind of companies but uh yeah
it's it's really hard to balance these
kind of incentives which companies have
and these kind of ethical concerns um
but that's why also we as individuals
should
um
take our responsibility as well I think
that's very especially given that if
you've come to a talk on data ethics
you're probably someone who has an
interest in that area and maybe is in a
position to really think about where
you're at with that just a couple of
questions we've got just a minute lesson
maybe I just asked the last one I've got
on here
um would you rather not build a model if
there's only
um if there's no good data would you
rather not build a model rather than
building a bad model where is the
balance would you say I think that's
going to be our last question I'm sorry
I know there's some more coming up
happy to also discuss this topic later
on um
it's it's a tough question to really
answer in general terms but
um we've seen it with the um this kind
of grading algorithm in the UK I think a
bad model has more harm than no model
because of course people have biases too
but in a sense mostly it's more likely
that people have different biases and
there is is no no General discrimination
against particular groups but you have
if you have it baked into a model it
kind of
um is really systematic and
reinforces itself so I I would be torn
towards not building the model in the
first place sure well thank you very
much Leah it's been a really awesome
talk to so so can we just give Leo
another big hand before you go